I just got remarried in
October and my husband and I you know
after the wedding really sat down and
took a a good look at our combined
finances we definitely made a lot of uh
debt choices independently and now
coming together trying to figure out how
we can tackle that hopefully you know
for the new year planning on you know
having a kid um I already have a
9-year-old daughter part of the thing
that that's a little bit frustrating is
you know between our combined finances
we're bringing in about
11,000 500 a month and still feel like
we can't you know we've only got about
3,000 in our savings and not able to
really contribute to retirement or
anything like that and so this becomes a
great math equation where we go how much
of margin can we create every month to
throw at that smallest debt that's all
we're focused on no saving no investing
we're not eating out